In this lesson we will talk about traffic
classification and shaping. We'll first talk about different ways
to classify traffic, then we'll talk about different traffic
shaping approaches. Then we'll talk about a traffic shaper
called a leaky bucket traffic shaper, then we'll
talk about an rT traffic shaper. Then we'll talk
about a token bucket traffic shape. And finally, we'll
talk about how to combine a token bucket shaper
with a leaky bucket shaper to build
what's called a composite shaper. The motivation here
is to control network resources and ensure that
no traffic flow exceeds a particular pre-specified rate.